la désinformation à son paroxysme quand
la définition même de l'objectivité fait
défaut à l'un des plus grands médias
américains
c'est comme ça que l'on pourrait résumer
en deux phrases elle ce reportage publié
par la cnn mais laissons parler les
images des images provenant des
téléphones portables ont émergé montrant
des colonnes armées et du matériel
militaire transportés par train vers la
frontière
sauf que ces fameux char ne proviennent
en aucun cas de la russie en réalité ces
images ont été tournées en ukraine et ce
matériel militaire et ukrainiens la
porte parole du ministère russe des
affaires étrangères
maria zakharova n'a pas tardé à faire
aux journalistes américains
une leçon de déontologie cher chaîne cnn
et son personnel amical
nous comprenons que vous n'avez pas le
temps de faire de la vérification des
faits vous qui êtes si profondément
ancrée dans la lutte idéologique au nom
du triomphe du libéralisme mais
présentait des chars ukrainien dans une
gare ukrainienne avec des wagons
ukrainien en arrière-plan
comme étant la préparation à la guerre
par la russie c'est un peu trop la
chaîne d'information américaine a
modifié dans la foulée la photo de
couverture de l'article mais pour
beaucoup d'observateurs cet épisode est
tout simplement indécent surtout dans ce
contexte très tendu la sienne n'a pour
l'instant pas répondu à maria zakharova
à mai aux états unis on pointe du doigt
un manque de professionnalisme et paie
avec et les dual henry stx est
pathétique c'est une faute
professionnelle journalistique c'est
quelque chose qui ne se fait pas une
faute
il n'y a aucune excuse tune kate lit au
fond les deux parties les corons que si
c'était le monde réel il devrait
normalement être horrifié et annie les
six day by day subi des têtes devraient
rouler mais vous savez ce qui va se
passer à rien non pas du tout le monde
s'en fout vous savez pourquoi et c'est
très intéressant parce que c'est cnn
c'est leur aptitude c'est leur excuse
leur camelot je suis
vous leur immunité est mieux loti wicca
relationnel n'en est pas à son coup
d'essai concernant la russie accusant
notamment moscou d'interférence dans les
élections américaines
souvenez-vous nous sommes en 2016
wikileaks dévoile une série d'e-mails de
campagne d'hillary clinton ou nous
découvre par exemple la manière de
gagner le vote des afro américains
l'équipe de campagne accusent le
gouvernement russe d'être responsables
de ces fuites et wikileaks d'aidé donald
trump la cnn peu de temps après affirme
avoir la preuve de ses accusations avec
un mail envoyé par un certain monsieur
ericsson prouvant l'existence de liens
entre donald trump et wikileaks
avant même la publication de ces emails
piratés mais la chronologie de la chaîne
est en fait erronée correction cet
article a été corrigée pour indiquer que
la date de l'e-mail était le 14
septembre 2016 et non le 4 septembre
2016 le titre a également été changée et
le tweet de donald trump junior qui a
publié un message sur wikileaks le 4
septembre 2016 supprimer un défaut de
dates qui provoque un véritable tollé
puisque ce mail est envoyé en réalité le
lendemain de la publication de wikileaks
donald trump n'a pas cessé par la suite
d'accuser la chaîne de cette news
la sienne a tellement été responsable de
fausses informations concernant la
russie que le vice président de la
chaîne a demandé depuis 2010 est à
d'être dorénavant consulter pour toute
histoire liée à la russie et apparemment
ce n'a pas été le cas pour ces charges
soit disant russe